Speaker 1: Let's talk today about Biden, AMEX,
President Joe Biden giving a speech yesterday
in Chicago where he very accurately and precisely
dismantles the trickle down trash of the American
right wing of the last, quite frankly, 40 years.
And it is actually getting to the point, you know,
not every president gets an omics named after
them. We know about Reaganomics. Certainly some
people have talked about Clinton nomics, but
there was no Bush Banamex, there was no Obama,
Amex or Obama and nomics, as the term may be.
Whatever. Call it what you want. The point here
is that President Joe Biden, whatever you think
of the guy personally, whatever you think about
Hunter Biden's documents or Joe Biden's newly
announced sleep apnea, which I will cover,
I have no interest in covering up Joe Biden's
sleep apnea and his CPAP machine, but we'll get to
that later. Whatever you think about it, we have a
very interesting economic situation where, despite
continued claims from Republicans that we are on
the brink of disaster and that la la la la. When
you actually look at the Western countries that
the U.S. compares itself to regularly, we've seen
more job creation and lower inflation under Joe
Biden, with just about every economic indicator
looking very strong. And here is indeed Joe Biden
yesterday in Chicago saying what many of us have
known for a long time, trickle down economics, the
idea that you give tax cuts to the rich and then
those benefits trickle down to everybody else. It
sounds so stupid when you say it because it's been
so widely debunked that it doesn't work.
Speaker 2: It is a fundamental break and
the economic theory has failed America's middle
class for decades now. It's called trickle down
economics, Fundamental economics trickle down. The
idea was, is believe that we should cut taxes for
the wealthy and big corporations. And I know some
about big corporations. There's more corporations
in Delaware, Inc, in every other state in the
union combined. I want them to do well. But I'm
tired of waiting for the trickle down.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it just never seems
to trickle down. And listen, if it is
not, how can I say this? I understand
most people would love for tax policy to be such
that they pay less. That's a normal thing. Even
when I file my taxes as someone who believes
that to have a functioning country, we need a
truly progressive tax system. When I actually go
and file my taxes, of course I have that moment
where I go, I would love to keep more of my money.
That's not what's wrong. But then when you think,
okay, but this isn't just about me. This is about
policy. This is about how to run a country. This
is how we have enough money to do the things
that rich developed countries are able to do
and should do. You realize that this trickle down
stuff doesn't work. Now, Joe Biden actually spoke
quite a bit about the economic indicators
that he pays attention to. And you all know,
I don't like to play these games with, oh, the
labor participation rate or all debt and deficit.
I just kind of tell it to you like it is. Joe
Biden actually has a great thing going on. If
you are president and you want to make the case
that the economy is good, he actually has the
data on his side and the statistics on his side.
Speaker 2: I know he couldn't go back to the same
failed policies when I ran. So I came into office
determined to change the economic direction of
this country, to move from trickle down economics,
whatever you want. On Wall Street Journal,
the Financial Times began to call Biden because I
didn't come up with a name, right? I really did.
I now claim it, but they're the ones who use the
first. I got asked by press person this morning,
Get on the helicopter in Washington. Why? When I
ask about Biden nomics a long time ago, you said
you didn't know what it was. I said I didn't
name him by name because I didn't realize The
Economist in The Wall Street Journal did. But I
think it's a plan that I'm happy to call nomics.
Yes. What are nomics is
working? When I took office, the
pandemic is raging and our economy is
reeling. Supply chains are broken, millions
of people are unemployed, Hundreds of thousands
of small businesses on the verge of closing after
so many had already closed, literally hundreds
of thousands on the verge of closing. Today,
the U.S. has the highest economic growth rate,
leading the world economy since the pandemic,
the highest in the world.
Speaker 1:
And of course, that is among the countries that
share sort of our level of development. Joe Biden
also, by the way, hitting Republicans for now,
taking credit for the very infrastructure bill
they opposed, including mentioning specifically
Tommy Tuberville. Tuberville. Who the hell knows?
Speaker 2: It's no surprise. Let's bring along
some converse. Yep. People strenuously opposed
voting against it when we had this going on.
They were this was kind of bankrupt America.
Well, there's a guy named Tuberville from Alabama.
Senator from Alabama. When I say strongly opposed
the legislation. Now he's telling his past. He
said, quote, It's great to see Alabama received
critical funds to boost ongoing broadband efforts.
Speaker 1:
All right. And then Joe Biden making the sign of
the cross there. So listen. I have no you know,
you guys, you know me by now. I have no interest
in gaslighting anybody here. To some degree,
we were going to see job recovery during this four
year stretch as we came out of COVID and as jobs
lost during COVID were were recovered. But that's
not all that we're seeing. There are millions of
additional jobs. There are, to some degree, the
economic indicators that we are seeing only have
a little bit to do with who's president of the
United States. But the point here is what we
were told was that Joe Biden was going to destroy
the economy and in fact, the economy, despite its
continued problems of inequality and wages aren't
as high as they should be. And all these different
things is quite an economy. And so biodynamics has
delivered results to the extent that we believe
the president has something to do with how the
economy is doing. 13 million jobs added, nearly
800,000 in manufacturing. It was Trump who said,
I'll bring back manufacturing, the clean energy
sector doing extraordinarily well. Construction
is improving strongest growth since the pandemic
of any Western rich country on a number of areas.
And I've talked about all of these little details
before, and it really adds up to a big story.
Biden nomics lowering costs for working families
in a number of different areas. We now see
inflation down for 11 months in a row. The child
tax credit expanded under Biden's American rescue
plan, has reduced the number of kids in poverty,
significantly reduced childcare costs. No one of
these things is a miracle, but all of these little
things do add up. We then had the bipartisan
infrastructure bill, so we're finally going to get
some of those improvements to roads and bridges
and ports and airports, airports and broadband.
It's not going to be what so many other countries
have. You look at broadband in South Korea,
you look at train travel in Europe, but we're not
there. We're not there. We have a long way to go,
but at least we're making some progress. So
we do now have this thing called by Dynamics,
and it includes actually working to strength,
strengthen the middle class, reducing inequality
a little bit, setting raising the low bar below
which we say we don't need to let anybody fall
below this bar and doing it by investing where it
makes sense clean energy, renewable technology,
safer technology, all of these different things.
So we don't praise Biden for being solely
responsible for all of these economic indicators.
There is a macroeconomic reality that is bigger
than the United States, but within that, within
these this group of countries are all OECD rich,
Western developed nations. However you want
to slice and dice it within that group,
the United States is doing particularly well. It's
not just an economic plan, really. It's more of a
vision that includes it includes, I don't want to
say equality, but it includes trying to write some
of the unbalanced circumstances that the last 40
years of attempts from the trickle down ours has
has created. And to that extent, it's hard not
to see it as a success. We're going to continue
watching the numbers. There's still plenty of
time left in this presidential term of Joe Biden
to see it go in a different direction. But it is
really tough to argue with the results so far.